So a while back we built a table out of snow
and let it freeze overnight.
Today it's time to find out who's the king of the ice
table.
Official king of the table draw.
Ok you start.
Roller chop.
No! A bit of sidespin in the shot.
Good serve!
Oh no!
I couldn't see anything my hat was above my eyes.
You lost the point.
I wanna see the video replay.
Yeah okay it was on.
Interesting change of conditions here.
Now it's really started to snow.
Good rally!
Had to go for the hard one.
Why is looping so hard?
Youshould just play it safe.
Uuuuh nice one!
Come on!
I was so ready for the forehand around the net.
Yeah I saw.
Nooo you got the low one.
Okay I need to start my comeback.
That's a proper way to start your comeback!
Youstill haven't learnt through all these years
that don't give me there!
That's the biggestmistake you can make.
But you still do it.
Noooo!
Was it still in play?
Yeah it was!
That was rally of the day!
Yeah of course I went for the big forehand!
No I can't keep...
Nice! That was smooth!
Noooo!
This is probably the bestreflex training there is.
Otto's reaction was reallygood.
Good comeback so far.
That was crazy forehand!
Whoah!
That was literally impossible to get.
Chole!
It touched? Did it touch?
Oooh that was nice!
Sneaky
No again!
Come on!
Ooh that was good!
Nouh!
Match point!
Yes!
Noo went for the big one.
Both playing it very safe.
Good save.
Your knee down tactic didn'twork.
Oh it's another match point to Emil.
Yes! Come on!
Winner!
Winner of the ice edition king of the table!
Good match! Good match!
Thanksfor watching, until next time!